what's to be said about dexter it burst
on the scene in 2006 with a pretty
catchy premise
that led to a lot of dark fun it was
basically
instantly popular and depending on who
you talked to
it was really good to great for two or
maybe even four
seasons it went on for a lot longer than
that though
and the eighth and final season is
considered awful by
just about everyone who's seen it that's
why it's a little surprising that it's
coming
back for a ninth season eight years
later and this video is gonna explore
everything there is to know about that
we got some teasers
a release date cast announcements and a
comic-con panel with some details and
hints for what to expect
to talk about that there's going to be
some spoilers about the first eight
seasons and this is your chance to leave
if you don't want to know how that
ended in the sneak peek trailer that
showtime released at the end of their
comic con
at home panel we learned that the
premiere date of dexter new blood
is november 7 2021 no big surprise
michael c hall is coming back as the
main character
couldn't really have dexter without that
but most of the original casts that are
still alive that were related to miami
won't be returning
according to the casting announcements
that are out there
the big news on that front was that
jennifer carpenter
who played dex's sister deborah will be
returning
you might think hey wait she's dead and
that's true
she was actually the last person to die
and dexter's last kill in the series
considering that he cut her life support
but you can follow
that thought up with one about how
dexter always interacted with dead
characters in the original run
most notably his adoptive father harry
the guy who gave him his code
also his brother brian moser aka the ice
truck killer
made a return in season six long after
he was killed at the end of season one
the best guess then is that deb will
come back in a similar way
and that seems like a good thing the two
siblings have sort of
opposite personalities and i think dex
talking with deb would be preferable to
harry at this point in the story
the other returning character they've
announced is another dead one the
trinity killer
it sounds like john lithgow will step
into the role once again
for a very brief appearance though
according to reports he was only on set
for an afternoon his return raised some
hardcore fans eyebrows
based on an alternate ending that's out
there the show's original showrunner
clyde phillips
who's returning for the new season left
after season four
as the show was coming to its end he
shared how he would have ended the
series if he'd stayed
basically his plan was to have the final
scene be
dexter waking up on the executioner's
table in a florida penitentiary
the events of the eight seasons would
have been him
remembering them as his life was
flashing in front of his eyes and he was
about to die
the idea was that when you saw the
gallery you would see all the people he
had
killed or had died because of his
actions watching his execution and when
he told the story he mentioned
the trinity killer would be there
considering this story was widely
circulated and talked about back then
it doesn't seem likely that he's still
going to deliver this
as the new ending but in the comic-con
panel he did promise that the
ending they're moving towards in new
blood would blow up the internet
last year when dexter's return was
announced there was a fair amount of
talk about
whether they would just undo what
happened in season eight
basically pretend it didn't happen we
know now that won't be the case
based on what we've seen and what
they've said the story will pick up
eight years after we first met the
bearded lumberjack version of dex
just to briefly recap how the show ended
dexter was planning to leave to start a
new life in argentina with his serial
killer girlfriend hannah and his son
harrison
that didn't work out because she was
being pursued by deb's boss from the
private detective agency
who's trying to collect her bounty deb
had been shot by
season 8's serial killer antagonist and
though it looked like she might pull
through when they took her to the
hospital
she ended up having a stroke after
surgery that left her brain dead
dexter was able to get revenge on her
killer while he was in custody
setting it up to look like self-defense
with a hurricane coming the hospital's
moving patients around to get ready
dexter slips in and disconnects the
machines that are keeping his sister
alive
he then leaves the hospital in his boat
leaving her body at the bottom of the
ocean
makes a call to hannah and learns that
she's boarding the flight to argentina
and that her
and harrison are gonna make it out and
then he steers the slice of life
directly into the storm
the wreckage is found and he's presumed
to be dead
hannah has made it to argentina and she
reads about his death online
there is a twist though he actually
faked his death
and is living in oregon under an assumed
identity
apparently working as a lumberjack
that's where things were left
as mentioned the finale wasn't something
fans or
critics liked but it did provide an
ending fast forward eight years
and now dexter is living in the
fictional town of iron lake new york
living under the alias jim lindsey which
is a nod to the author of the book
series that the show's based on
he's working in a sporting goods store
he's in a relationship with a new
girlfriend who also
happens to be a police officer and from
what we see in the trailer it seems like
he's trying to keep his dark passenger
at bay
there are some contradictions if you
really think about it though
he's in a small town which could be an
effort
to keep the possible options to a low
it would be hard for him to act out
there according to harry's code
at the same time he's staying close to
the local police that gives him
access to information and he has access
to hunting gear through his work which
includes a lot of knives
the sneak peek trailer shows him in what
looks like a therapy session
when asked how he's doing he replies
that it's been a whirlwind
we hear him say that he's always had his
demon so he went away
and he's standing outside a log cabin
home in outdoor
gear around town the locals all seem to
know him by name and everyone seems to
be friendly
there's a shot of him with his
girlfriend where she's looking at him
lovingly and from the comic-con panel we
know that this is a serious relationship
and that they've been together for a
while there's shots of him at work doing
his job
perhaps that's not entirely satisfying
and we also
see him in several shots sharpening his
blades looking at knives
looking at a straight razor that he's
carrying in his hand looks like he might
be going after someone
and we hear him say that sometimes he
has an urge
too strong to ignore there's also a bit
of action we see what looks like a car
chase
an unknown female character running
looking like someone's after her
and dexter himself running where it
looks like he might have been in a
physical struggle based on some marks on
his face
there's blood on the snow which he
covers up and a tactical team
breaking down someone's door on the
surface he's got a normal life and
appears to be fitting
in the question isn't really if he'll
kill though
in an earlier teaser we got a look at a
reflection in the window that he was
looking out where you can clearly see
someone wrapped in plastic wrap on a
kill table behind him
the question is has he been keeping his
urges under control enough to keep up
the facade
or if he really was trying not to kill
at all
while he's in this small town what is
the situation that's going to get him
going again
it's possible that this mass character
we see with a rifle
might be the most likely suspect as far
as new characters we do
see a shot of clancy brown standing next
to dexter
and there's some crime scene tape up in
front of them so they're looking at some
kind of crime
brown who i always think of as viking
from the movie
bad boys is playing a character named
kurt
codwell which they say is a villain the
official description
says caldwell was born and raised in the
town of iron lake
in fact some consider him the unofficial
mayor of their small town
he's realized the american dream by
going from driving big rigs just like
his father did
to now owning several trucks and the
local truck stop
powerful generous loved by everyone
he's a true man of the people if he's
got your back
consider yourself blessed but should you
cross curt
or hurt anyone that he cares for god
help you
considering they're billing him as a
villain dexter might find himself on
kurt's wrong side
or i suppose it's possible that he's the
killer dex will be hunting
i mentioned his girlfriend who's played
by julia jones
she was in one of my favorite episodes
of westworld
and the bottom line is that he's going
to be surrounded by a whole new cast of
characters
there really aren't that many miami
characters still alive and since he's
in self-imposed exile it wouldn't be
great for him
if any of them found out he was still
alive for what it's worth
most of the actors have said they
weren't going to be involved in the
reboot but i suppose you can't rule out
a cameo
if something happens like he dies at the
end
and we see them learning about it or
something along those lines
one of the more interesting new
characters is played by jamie chung
who recently appeared in lovecraft
country
she's playing molly who is a famous true
crime podcaster
could she be in iron lake following
leads related to the bay harbor butcher
as far as loose ends in the final season
there really aren't many
harrison is still alive and that should
matter to dexter
but he was okay with leaving him with
hannah as things were left the actress
that played her
has said in interviews that she's not
returning for season 9
but there was a short teaser where
dexter throws a picture
of him and his son into a campfire in
voiceover we heard a clip from season 4
saying want to know a secret daddy kills
people
that feels like it opens the door for a
harrison reunion
and at least the fan site dexter daily
is reporting that harrison is confirmed
to be returning
and the actor who's playing him is a
teenager
so there's a lot of potential for
dexter's new life in this sleepy little
town to get turned on its head
when season 9 was announced last year a
popular take was that
no one wanted more dexter after that
awful
final season as i mentioned people were
actively wondering if they would retcon
the ending based on the negative
reaction
of course that's not the case obviously
there's a lot of people that love this
show
especially love this character but those
takes weirdly are what got me interested
in the reboot
not that i wanted to see a retcon if i'm
being honest i think i stopped following
the show sometime in season
six because of the hype i did catch up
by the time the ending
aired though and just was really kind of
underwhelmed but i wasn't invested
enough at that point to be
actually affected what catches my
interest now
is what do you do after that the
original showrunner is back and many die
hard fans believe
that his leaving is what caused the show
to go downhill
and i do think there's something to that
but really for me the problem that
dexter had even before
that was that it fell into this pattern
where the tension
came from whether or not he would get
caught each season they would ratchet
that tension
up only for him to get out of the
situation and then start the whole
cycle over again in the next installment
you can only do that for so long
until it starts to not work till the
tension diminishes
so now here we are with the chance for
them to make a real ending for the
character and he is a good one i did a
re-watch of the first four seasons
recently and that's what really holds up
the premise of the main character
and the performance of michael c hall
while i may not have wanted a new season
of dexter
i find myself kind of excited to watch
it again
partly out of nostalgia and partly to
see what they can do for a show that has
occupied every worst ending list that's
been published since
2013. to his credit clyde phillips is
motivated by that
he knows what people think about how the
series went he had his own ideas about
it
and he said that they weren't undoing
anything that happened they're coming at
it thinking they can make something that
can improve what didn't work in the past
something that can be a proper ending
for the series
and i think that's a good place to leave
things
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon